The Joe Rogan experience,
that's what a real friend does right where you go,
Huh?
I gotta actually reassess them.
You know,
I love Michael Schirmer's quote,
Veuve read,
uh,
a,
I'm doing myself a great disjustice injustice,
but bring up Michael Shermer right now because I'll be a rape apologist because
I don't know if you know about this.
He was accused of,
uh,
of doing something improper,
improper meaning getting a girl drunk and having sex with her crazy that people
are calling that a lot of people are calling that rape now.
You never done that.
I don't know if that happened.
I don't know what happened.
You're drunk.
My point is I just needed to address,
uh,
just to put it out there.
But the quote that is that he has is that a lot of people that are very smart,
believed dump things because they can explain them and they can argue them very
well.
And so they think they're doing well and winning in the argument.
So that may be their point.
Makes Sense.
But it really becomes like a sort of circular ego argument.
Sounds,
sounds good.
They've got a good sounding argument to be talked to like Michael Murphy and uh,
he,
he's very eloquent.
Yes.
It used to base a bit less eloquent.
Now it's,
but he,
he,
he's very convincing.
He's very personable person and you can easily get sucked into things like that.
And then you start repeating the same arguments yourself.
Yes.
And you're convincing yourself because if you're an outgoing person,
you're eloquent to yourself.
Well,
it's also in being a smart person and most of us are at least somewhat
competitive that we want to be.
Right.
And it's what you were talking about earlier about certain skeptics being
aggressive and they use skepticism as a game.
It Chow tallying up a social score.
Yeah.
I mean it becomes a debate in the old fashioned sense of a debate where it's
like one person has to argue this,
the other person argues the opposite thing and then they fight it out and the
best debater winds,
it becomes about debating rather than about finding what is true and what is not
true.
Yeah.
That's,
that is a real problem with being able to,
to put it all aside and actually like look at what the fuck is really going on.
They end up saying things that are wrong because the too hasty to come up with
an explanation for things.
So they'll end up like,
you know,
just saying,
oh that's,
that's not,
that's not a chem trail,
that's a smoke from the planes just because it's the first thing that comes into
their head because the debunkers and they think that if they can think of
something,
they got that thing where they think they are intelligent and they are somewhat
intelligent,
but people fool themselves as to how intelligent they actually are.
So even in debunkers can you caught their own deceit?
Very.
It's very annoying from my perspective as well because I get people coming onto
my site and then they try to debunk things,
but they're,
they,
they say things that are wrong scientifically wrong,
and then you have to end up like correcting the debunkers as well.
Will that ever ends?
Conti debunkers fully agree.
There are a lot of content goes quite a few,
you know?
Sure.
It's easily today.
It's easy to be when you're also frustrated with your own vision of the world
and then when someone comes along saying they have documented proof,
the loch ness monster is real and you're like the fuck you do shit shithead.
You don't.
It's hard.
It's hard to say,
what is it,
sir?
What is this proof where way of you've got this proofs toward me.
I measure it stems from the evidence you were asking for and the Ufo thing last
night,
was it?
Yeah.
They don't have evidence.
They have windows tetanus testimony.
They had like crappy photo has no empirical evidence.
There's not that sort of like let's,
let's see.
Some measurable evidence,
positive pregnancy tests in high demand on craigslist.
I'll read it again.
How crazy is that shit?
Positive pregnancy.
Yes.
So like just to make somebody marry you maybe.
Exactly.
They advertised tests for women hoping to trick their boyfriends into popping
the question.
Wow.
Whoa,
that's crazy.
They're only 25 bucks to 25 bucks.
Positive pregnancy test 25 bucks in Buffalo,
New York.
Yes,
you saw that right?
I'm willing to selling positive pregnancy tests.
Ever since I became pregnant,
I have been asked numerous times for a positive test,
so I decided to start charging for it.
Exclamation point.
I will take the test the same day.
You want to pick it up?
I don't care what you use it for.
Not My business.
Wink.
Wow.
I'm always near my phone,
so just send an email.
Wow.
That's kind of crazy.
Some crazy pregnant bitch.
Just pissing on chicks.
Pregnancy tests all day.
That's her business.
Twenty five bucks a pop.
She's got a basket full of.
I'm just pissing on him like crazy drinking giant jugs,
Koolaid pissing all over these things and then like two days before the wedding
you fake a miscarriage and then everyone buys you better toys and presence gives
you more money.
Say,
oh,
that's so rude.
You're evil.
I don't even think most evil woman could think that way.
Actually.
They might right now my time at holy.
Exactly right,
man.
I had somebody do a fake pregnancy with me once.
Remember that shit stupid.
Just so I would give her money.
Yeah,
there's a lot of these positive pregnancy tests,
things where they're advertising these things and whether asking for them to
just kind of weird,
man,
I would buy just to smell them.
How much is that?
Twenty $5.
It's a smell.
20 five bucks just to smell some random chicks pis.
If you're a real freak,
you might go for it.
I wonder if there's a.
You could sell that for 25 bucks here.
Send me a rag and I'll pee on it.
I saw outside the realm of possibility.
It's crazy though.
Manipulation.
Just some like that's their,
their relationship is just a constant battle like that.
So it's gotta be a weird way to enter into a lifelong commitment for fake
pregnancy test.
I mean,
what if it all works out?
Happy you got married and one day you're sitting around.
She goes,
honey,
I'm going to say something really funny.
Remember when I had that,
uh,
that miscarriage,
I was never really pregnant.
I was fake.
I needed,
I knew you'd be happy eventually.
So look,
I was right.
Here we are 60 years later.
The guys like,
shit,
I don't care.
Honey.
I love you.
It's got to be the responsibility of being the one who could possibly get
pregnant.
Boy does that fucking changed the game.
That's why they say that one of the biggest changes in behavior for human beings
was when birth control was invented because then for the first time women had
some sort of control over their own ability to get pregnant or get pregnant,
their own contraception.
They didn't have to count on,
I got to wear a rubber.
That guy doesn't want to wear a rubber.
Otherwise I got to get like an Iud or diaphragm.
Those things fucking slip out.
Especially if you have a funder is tremendous.
Waterfall of loads slamming into that thing.
They can't take a good shot.
You know,
they're good,
they're good for like the average load,
but you get like a wilt chamberlain load and they're just fine.
Swear around.
Flows that sucker sideways like one of those big revolving doors and Indiana
Jones,
that's what it does.
The load headset and opens it up.
That was a big change apparently for women.
So I'm asking,
Oh shit,
itunes or recording to server the fuck outta here.
Server.